حصل على وسام الصداقة
يوسف يوسف المخرج
معهد البحوث
أمراض العيون
مدينة موسكو
[موسيقى]
عزيزي فلاديمير فلاديميروفيتش
زملائي الأعزاء ، إنه لشرف لي
مكافأة شرف عظيم المسؤولية و
raker المنزل وبعد ذلك الحياة 20 أخرى
قبل سنوات ، كانت بلادنا صعبة
الوضع الاقتصادي والاجتماعي
خلال هذه السنوات العشرين ، أنت فلاديمير محترم
قام فلاديميرتش بعمل رائع
كانت هناك تغييرات كبيرة في كل شيء
مجالات حياتنا الآن روسيا
ليس فقط ممكنًا وعسكريًا
القوى ولكن أيضا يأخذ أحمق و
مناصب في الاقتصاد والعلوم
بفضل هذه التغييرات
حصلنا على هذه العين مفيدة
تطور مثير للإعجاب و
أصبحت واحدة من الأكثر احتراما
مؤسسات البحث و
فقط روسيا وأوروبا في الحادي والعشرين
العام الذي أعلنت عنه
أعلن عام العلوم والتكنولوجيا
دعم وزارتنا
تم تقديم دعم كبير
معهدنا و
تلقى قاعدة مادية لـ
إجراء العلمية الأساسية
البحث والعمل الطبي
تغيرت جوهريا المادة
موقف موظفينا خلال
السنوات الأخيرة في إطار علمي
المتخصصين لدينا التعاون
معهد مع مؤسسة الدولة
روستك يدا بيد 8 سيرجي فيكتور
تطور Chemezova وتنفذ في 3
الممارسة الروسية هي حقا مبتكرة و
طرق فعالة للغاية للتشخيص و
علاج مثل هذا مهم اجتماعيا
أمراض العيون مثل الجلوكوما
إعتام عدسة العين وآفات الأوعية الدموية
تستند هذه الأساليب على
الوقت مع الطب
تخصصات الرقمنة صباحا
الغازية والدعامات عزيزي
فلاديمير فلاديميروفيتش
شكرا لجهودكم
أصبح علمنا أكثر عالمية
قيد الطلب
قيد التنفيذ حاليا
العمل على إنشاء على أساسنا هو
هنا أ
السريرية العلمية الدولية و
شكل على الطريق السريع والخام والداخل
بما في ذلك باللغة السريانية العربية
جمهورية مع مثل هذا الطلب لتسليط الضوء
الحاجة لمثل هذا المركز
ممثلي وفد السلسلة
خلال لقاء مع الوزير
التعليم والعلوم في الاتحاد الروسي
فالكو أنت فاليري لي كالاتش
أتذكر نفسي كطالب عادي
الذي جاء إليه منذ أكثر من 30 عامًا
روسيا تدرس الآن أنا رئيس واحد
من المؤسسات العلمية الرائدة لدينا
الجوانب
لسنوات عديدة موجودة في أسطورة
الحلم الأمريكي نجحت
لتحقيق حلمي الروسي
أريد أن أناشد جميع العلماء الشباب
جائزة المستثمرين الوهميين
تعال إلينا في روسيا كخبير اقتصادي
الاستثمار في روسيا الحب روسيا هي
سيتم الرد عليك وأخيراً أريد
أشكر والدي 5 نظرة
من فوق وافرحوا بهذه المكافأة
النجاح لأشكر أساتذتي
والتي وفقًا لـ is-3 ليست كبيرة ووفقًا لـ
الجودة البشرية والمهنة
لقد ساعدوني لأكون جيدًا
طبيب متخصص جيد و
المنظم أريد أن أشكر بلدي
المرضى الذين اختاروني باعتباري
الطبيب كجراح كشخص و
طاقم معهدنا مشترك
جائزتنا مرة أخرى شكرا جزيلا
عزيزي فلاديمير فلاديمير